this year has been crazy for everybody
um but to have outdoor space where i can
go for walks with archie and we can go
for walks as a family and with the dogs
and
maybe go to hikes or go you know down to
the beach which is so close
meghan markle and prince harry's son
archie made an adorable little cameo
during the couple's 90-minute interview
special with oprah winfrey
they're loving their new life and they
also love what it gives to archie
i think it's worth pointing out that
another of the reasons that they left
was so that archie could have a normal
ordinary childhood that he wasn't always
under the scrutiny of the media
spotlight and i think
at their home they have the space they
are surrounded by nature
and they're left alone you know there
haven't been
intrusive paparazzi pictures of archie
in the family because
they won't tolerate it they will take
action archie who turns two
in may appears in this sweet footage of
a recent outing with his parents
and our hearts are totally melting
i guess the highlight for me is
sticking him on the back of the bicycle
in his little baby seat
and take him on his bike rise or
something which i never i was able to do
when i was young
i can see him on the back and he's got
his arms out he's like whoa
chatting chatting chatting again palm
tree house and
all this sort of stuff yep we learned
baby archie has a
pretty impressive vocabulary oh my gosh
she's on a roll
in the past couple weeks it has been
hydrate which is just but also whenever
anyone leaves the house he's like drive
safe
drive safe and during a recent
appearance on the late late
show with james corden harry shared
archie's seriously impressive first word
how are you finding fatherhood my son is
now
just over a year and a half he is
hysterical
he's got the most amazing personality
he's already putting three four words
together he's already singing songs
what was his first word uh crocodile
crocodile
three syllables i mean it's just a
perfect idyllic
childhood for archie who by all accounts
has settled in
amazingly well don't forget this is his
this is his second
move archie moved from britain to canada
and then from canada to la there's been
a lot of change
in his life and i think as a couple they
just want to give him
stability and make sure that he he feels
happy
he feels safe and he is a very happy
very secure
very joyful little boy before the oprah
interview special aired on sunday
the last time archie was seen publicly
was in this sweet video that megan
shared in may
2020 look the duck is so hot
he's getting a drink of water no the
rabbit is so hot he's cooling off his
ears that's the sun and what's that fish
let's turn the page let's see what else
happens and the cute factor
is only expanding as megan is currently
pregnant with the couple's second
child during the special megan waited
for harry to join her with oprah to
reveal the sex of baby number two
due this summer we're the new addition
to your family
megan said she wanted to wait until you
were here to tell us
is it a boy or is it a girl
you can tell her my good friend no no
it's a girl
oh yeah you know i think the the arrival
of new life in the family is always an
exciting moment from for anyone and
i'm sure harry and megan having a second
child will be a moment that brings
everyone
closer together it's a moment that one
can't ignore and
i think despite all the difficulties
that everyone has faced over the past
few years
we are at the tail end of it now